texting is the death of romance are you
out of your mind not even a little there
is nothing like that thing where you
meet the person you have the first date
and the next day they text like can't
stop thinking about our date last night
that's the best text in the world
there's nothing more romantic than that
we live in this world where texting
exists you know we're also living in a
world where we have so much expectation
and emphasis on texting literally I do
see people like well he hasn't texted me
I'm like text dis just started in the
history of man text is so new God forbid
you say something you don't kind of want
to or you worry about how it comes off
then your day is ruined because you send
a text that's made you he and vulnerable
or they send a text and you can't figure
it out and so you sit there with all
your friends trying to decode it I hate
texting I hate
it